we are pleased to announce Android 2.2
there are four areas we'd like to
highlight in this video we're working to
continue improving overall speed and
performance on Android in Android 2.2
the newly introduced dalvik JIT compiler
delivers a 2 to 5x performance boost the
CPU bound code compared to Android 2.1
in this demo version of the game replica
Island the screen turns red when the CPU
is unable to keep the game simulation
thread above 30 frames per second here
the Android 2.2 device with JIT
maintains a game simulation framerate
above 35 while the 2.1 device quickly
goes below 30 developers can use android
cloud-to-device messaging to easily
enable alerts send a phone and two-way
sync functionality for their apps with
this API an app server can send
authenticated messages to the Google
server which would push the message to
the app on a user's device in this
example a developer has used android
cloud-to-device messaging to enable a
URL send a phone extension from the
desktop browser that automatically opens
the push page with the appropriate app
here Google Maps the app backup API
enables any app to have its data backed
up and then restored when installed on a
new device the feature is controlled by
users via the automatic restore setting
on their device
with Android 2.2 developers can specify
whether they want their app installed on
a devices SD card for apps residing on
the SD card users can move the app from
the SD card to internal storage and back
from the managed application settings
Android 2.2 introduces the ability to
use one's phone as a portable hotspot
users can activate portable hotspot on
their phone then connect their computer
to the portable hotspot to get internet
access we're continuing to make the
browser better and faster Android 2.2
introduces the v8 JavaScript engine
which provides a 2 to 3x improvement in
JavaScript rendering times compared to
Android 2.1 you can see the difference
in these side-by-side visualizations of
the respective SunSpider javascript
benchmarking test results we're
introducing several new features to
Android Market users can choose to let
an app auto update as long as
permissions remain unchanged
users can also update all apps with
unchanged permissions with a single
click application error reports will
provide to developers app crash and
freeze reports submitted by users these
reports will be available to developers
through their Android Market publisher
account to learn more about Android 2.2
please go to our website
developer.android.com